but now sudden you've got parents
showing up you've got parents fighting
and pushing back I mean you have that
story uh about the uh the parent that
the uh a foyer request oh we got we
actually yeah yeah I pulled this up so
we've got this from the daily signal Mom
says School Board threatened to sue her
for seeking public information on
critical race Theory and curriculum the
craziest thing about it is she found out
because in their meeting minute like
their their itinerary it says discussion
action filing lawsuit against Nicole
Solis to challenge filing over 160 apra
requests this is a mom who said I just
want documents on the curriculum to see
if you're teaching kids critical race
Theory and then before she gets any
notification they're discussing filing a
lawsuit against her over this what are
they hiding and see this is the mom that
in 2020
they went after the Suburban soccer mom
orange man bad whatever but now because
of their overreach they just made that
Mom an activist and they just made that
Mom engaged in the political process and
that is going to be the difference as we
go forward it really and Lydia and I
were talking about this driving up here
too often people have just focused on
the federal government I I know who my
congressman my Senator I'm voting for
president nothing else now people are
starting to realize the school board and
the city council that level of
governance that touches you the most Tip
O'Neill said all politics are local now
people are getting engaged and that is
scaring the bejesus out of the left and
you know you know what I think a lot of
people are realizing too how important
their Governors are a lot of people
didn't pay attention to this and so we
were talking about I hope they pay
attention to the race that I'm in oh
that's the point right so we were I
can't remember what we were talking to
we're talking about Ron DeSantis and
maybe a trump DeSantis ticket and the
fear from some of these people in
Florida is like but if you take away
Rhonda Sanders from Florida and he
enters a presidency that doesn't control
the the Congress or the courts then you
end up deep powering you said this
because he is an effective governor in
Florida and that's what people are
starting to realize is that the states
are the most important entity and then
from the states it goes down to those
the county commissions to the city
councils to the school boards and that's
where Republicans have not done a real
good job of focusing on previously and
that has been a big turn that we saw in
the state of Texas we want back a lot of
school board seats we want back a lot of
city council seats because we got people
engaged we got people focusing on that
in our Municipal level elections this
past may you know you got you got to
understand though how uh I think these
people are evil because what they're
doing is
these critical race theorists they want
to bring what we call critical race
applied principles or Crap into these
schools and they will move from Blue
cities Democrat cities into rural areas
into red areas Run for the board with no
political affiliation and then once
they're in indoctrinate the kids yes so
we're seeing this in West Virginia in
areas that are deep red you got Maga
Flags Trump Flags there are flags that
say F Biden everywhere but for some
reason the schools are adamant about
critical race applied principles being
taught to these kids
and it's because many of the parents
weren't paying attention they are now
they are now and you were seeing these
videos of the moms showing up at this
meeting screaming there was a one really
viral video of that that black man
saying his kids are being told they
can't succeed think about how Insidious
and nefarious it is to tell that Man's
children they can't succeed that's
you're you're trying to make the next
generation of victims and that's what
Progressive socialism has to have I mean
if you're a Victor why do you need them
okay why do you need the the handout why
do you need to be told to stay at home
and we'll send you a check you know I
want to get out and I want to work for
myself and that's that's the corruption
that's the the undermining of the fabric
of America that we see and that is
really the liberty and freedom that
you're talking about in the ability to
go out with your own mind and do for
yourself but when they take that away
then all of a sudden you have these
young people like you're saying that
America sucks America's horrible
America's bad the biggest
institutionalization happened over the
past year when they locked everybody
down everybody on shut down the
businesses and then put them on
government payments and now these people
are stuck in it you can't just cancel it
they become institutionalized yep so how
are you gonna you're getting 16 an hour
on average from these payments you can't
be evicted
why are you going to go find a job
somewhere that pays sixty dollars an
hour get it for free and that's how they
back in went into a living wage
that's right they couldn't get it
through a legislative process so what
did they do they put people out of work
they backended it and they they went and
destroyed and decimated the Mom Pop
stores all the small businesses and now
they are dependent upon the government
but I think the the it's it's it's an
exploitation of the weakness of many of
these people and the circumstances many
people find themselves in mostly in
cities of course out here we've been
growing a lot of our own food it's a
rugged individualism once you get
outside this that's right uh but even
myself growing up in the inner city of
Atlanta Georgia we had our own garden
and you know got back there with my dad
and we worked the garden we grew our own
food and whatever but how many how much
of that do you see today but people need
to they've got to exactly when the
government comes and says now you're
dependent upon us you can say I'll grow
my own food it kind of started off like
as Americans we were all kind of
decentralized we had our state we had
our local farms we worked locally and
then it slowly started to federalize
over the 1800s and became more and more
centralized and now with the Internet
it's shattering and decentralizing again
because you can see like a guy a local
guy farming makes a YouTube channel has
a 1.6 million followers and people start
emulating his local Behavior locally and
you see like Ron DeSantis is a super
famous guy who's a governor who like 20
or 30 years ago you might not even know
his name ah but now what are they doing
you have the Facebook you have the
twitters and the YouTubes that are going
out and saying and that content we're
going to censor yeah and it's pressure
like the the Iran quote that's why I
explained to people they're not outright
Banning us they're slowly slowly Banning
channels they they've given Stephen
Crowder several strikes they're really
close trying to get get it getting rid
of him and one of the strikes Crowder
got was for quoting CDC data they don't
care now for us we get the applied
pressure that's where people mention hey
I don't get notifications for your
videos anymore it's weird that somebody
would come and watch this show every day
we do it at 8pm and then YouTube would
think they don't like here's the
YouTube's argument is if people don't
click the notifications and don't engage
in the content we're not going to notify
them anymore even if they ask for the
notifications then how is it we have
people saying I watch a show every day
I'm not getting notifications anymore or
I was unscribed unsubscribed from your
channel these are the things that people
have been feeling for some time and it's
the pressure they put on you because
here's here's what they want
they isolate the audience they can watch
a show like this
so that over time we don't get new
viewers but we slowly slowly lose
viewers unless they bleed you out right
however I think we've been doing a
particularly good job I think Crowder
has we are growing regardless that's why
I say sharing this video and sharing the
videos of the creators you like shuts
down that attempt to put obstacles on
our way they're they're going to give as
many advantages as possible to all of
the left channels these these podcasts
appear on the front page you've never
used a computer before you open it up
you turn on YouTube Boom there's a
left-wing mainstream establishment
podcast
for stuff like this anti-establishment
or right-wing content nah it's not going
to happen they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna push you down they're
gonna hide you from from the main
algorithm you're not gonna see what's
happening but isn't it understanding
again Lydia and I we had great
conversation driving up from uh Reagan
Airport this is the 1984. this is the
Brave New World that we're living in and
you know young people I just got to ask
why do you want to hang out with control
freaks
I mean if you're on a college campus why
do you want to hang out with the people
that are going to tell you what you can
see what you can eat what you can wear
what you can drive you know all of this
stuff I thought you know me being a dad
now grandpa you know my daughters always
say leave me alone let me do my own
thing but now you've got you know big
government coming in and telling you
exactly everything you know flying up
here and we were discussing this I am
sick and tired of hearing the constant
drone in the airport the TSA the law
says that you must wear a mask in in the
airport and not failing to wear a mask
will result in the fine or criminal
penalties and I'm thinking say what law
there's never been a law I think Thomas
Massey tweeted this we never voted on
that that's what I said there's never
been a law and what is a law I mean I
remember Schoolhouse Rock and it kind of
taught you how you get to become usar
for the bill and then you become a law
there was never a law
that says that we have to wear a mask in
airports or or you know wherever but see
when you are constantly droning people
with this messaging and what you see out
there in the public space then all of a
sudden people become the Mindless
Lemmings and they just accept it much
the same as you saw in 1984 and so I
would say to everybody that's out there
the next time you're in an airport or
someplace and someone says that you know
you have to follow this law ask the
person what show me the law when was it
when was it passed when was it signed
because it was not and so we are moving
away from being a constitutional
republic to be in a constitutional
monarchy where someone's just sitting
back and signing stuff it's it's not
even necessarily a monarchy it's
something it's despotism it's it's yes
you you saw it with these Governors
totalitarian yeah it was a remarkable uh
Cuomo he killed 15 000 people yeah and
nothing happens yeah he's gonna get away
with it he got away with it as far as I
can tell right yeah he will
that's horrifying it really really is or
he was warmer and everyone else he was
warned that if he put sick people in
these nursing homes he would kill them
and he had the mercy vessel he had the
Javit Center kill the people instead and
and that's it he gets away with it the
only Scandal that erupts okay so that
was a bit of a scandal but then oh no he
inappropriately talks to women and
touched them I mean that's bad for sure
but wow he can kill 15 000 people and
the media is more concerned that he was
inappropriate with women yeah he did the
Bill Clinton you know maybe just grab us
okay
it's uh I'll tell you one thing
watching some of these stories about
schools and the indoctrination of
children
um I'm mixed in my pessimism and
optimism I'm optimistic Steve Bannon
said something that when these mothers
see what their kids are being taught
there's going to be a major revolt and
it's going to cause massive change and I
think he's right I think absolutely I
think when a little kid comes home and
tells their mom they're evil and they
hate them the mom's going to be like
what happened to my baby like they're
not gonna stand for that but I'll tell
you what makes me really optimistic is
what you're talking about with the
states the power the states have and
we've seen it Ron DeSantis hitting it
out of the park Texas is doing pretty
good pretty good I think maybe when
you're uh when you're in there yeah I
mean we lost some 10 000 small
businesses and and really you know Ron
DeSantis is the gold standard right now
yeah and you know there are a lot of
things look our border we should not be
sitting around asking for a mother may I
from the federal government we should be
doing everything possible to protect and
secure our border I want to follow up on
that a little if you were gonna
establish the National Guard like to
protect the Border how would that work
long term would they stay there for long
periods of time they stay there until we
get this thing under control they stay
there until we have you know driven the
cartel uh into to being irrelevant uh
they stay there until we make sure that
we get that situation because you got to
stem the flow uh and then you have the
ability to you know start the
deportation start arresting people start
getting them out of the state but you
got to stem the flow want to stem in the
flow right now would it would it be like
building facilities for them to live at
on the border and then you just line up
like basically bases National Guard
bases well I mean you can set up some
temporary type of housing but the bottom
line is that you get biometric data and
you say have a great day and go back
across the the Rio Grande River I mean
you're not coming into Texas to hang out
okay you you come across and that's the
deterrent
that that's the deterrent that was there
that remain in Mexico policy of
President Trump that the body
Administration flipped and I think it's
section 42 which is the you know the
covet uh emergency uh uh order that
President Trump put in place if they
left that then Katie bar the door
there's even more people that's going to
come across I think it's it's remarkable
that
taking control of your borders
is racist according to Democrats well
you know like I said I ain't really
black I'm sorry but again but then again
you know Tim that's what I'm saying I'm
not responding right to those just do it
just do it right and and that's the
problem of Republicans because they put
themselves in the Box in the in the
corner uh that the left is trying to
create for them it's just saying you
know I I'm tired of your name calling
we're going to do what's right by the
rule of law absolutely thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time